you absolutely
destroyed tonight if i was at home right
now you would be getting my vote the
winner
of canada's got talent
is
janik fournier
meet canada's newest champ have you said
it have you said i am the winner and and
this moment i don't realize so sorry i'm
in a dream
[Applause]
it's crazy
and janik
fournier
oh my god what happened
what what has happened pinch me please
pinch me did you look out to the
audience and look for your family yes
my son is sorry i'm so proud i'm so
proud to my
my son is with me i adopted two children
with down syndrome it's amazing and it's
a
it's a crazy i choose to bring you one
with me for make a lot of
memories yesterday said mom you do a
very good show
like you're so beautiful
your story
is really really incredible and there's
simon cowell in the audience he came on
the stage and he speak with me
five minutes he said to me you're
amazing you're beautiful humans you are
performing for america's got talent the
pressure are you ready yes i'm ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]